TIKTOK BAN:
The United States wants to ban TikTok.
They say that TikTok is Chinese spyware designed
to intrude on the privacy and lives of Americans,
and there is some truth to this. I mean, TikTok
doesn’t even try to hide it. If you go onto
their privacy policy page, they clearly list out
exactly what they collect. They of course collect
the classic stuff like what device you’re using,
your IP address, and your location. But they also
collect so more sus items like your biometrics
including your faceprint and voiceprint,
and that’s just the things that they admit to.
Who knows what other data the CC, I mean TikTok,
may be collecting and what exactly they’re
doing with this data. To be honest though,
TikTok’s data collection is not all that different
from Facebook’s or Google’s or even Apple’s but
since they’re a Chinese company, countries have
been much more cautious. In fact, several notable
countries have already banned the app like India
who banned it nearly 3 years ago. The US has also
started taking action. Earlier this year, dozens
of college campuses banned the use of TikTok
on school Wifi. TikTok has also been banned on
government devices and its CEO has been grilled in
Congress. But likely the scariest part for TikTok
is the fact that both sides of the government
are uniting on this issue. Some democrats have
even gone as far as admitting that Donald Trump
was right about TikTok the entire time. That’s
when you know you’re really screwed. But, if you
thought that TikTok was gonna lay down and take
this beating, you’d be mistaken. 3 years ago, a
ban was not something that they were anticipating,
meaning that they had to do as the US said
including selling themselves to Oracle. But, this
time, they’ve had plenty of time to prepare and
it looks like they already have an extensive three
phase plan in place. They’re currently working on
the 3rd phase of this plan which is by far the
most evil as they’re essentially buying out a
bunch of Americans. So, join me as we explore
TikTok’s sneaky plan to avoid getting banned.
PHASE 1 - STRIKE THE TENT:
Coming out on top on any deal is quite easy.
The key is to have leverage. 3 years ago,
America had all the leverage as it was TikTok that
was dependent on America. They were dependent on
American creators, American viewers, and most
importantly, American consumerism and addiction.
These things are still very much true which
gives the US government quite a bit of power. So,
the key for TikTok is to overcome this dependency
and the easiest way to do that is to ensure that
the US is even more dependent on TikTok. The first
step in making this the reality was addressing the
American economy by launching TikTok ads in June
of 2020. To be honest, the usage of TikTok ads is
still quite low. Most brands just don’t want to
get involved with short form cringe content. But,
a lot of dropshippers and ecommerce gurus have
apparently made it work leading to a decent amount
of revenue. In fact, TikTok is expected to pull
in $8.75 billion worth of revenue this year and
$11 billion worth or revenue next year just from
the US. But wait a minute, doesn’t this just make
TikTok even more dependent on the US? Well, that’s
how it appears at first glance but it’s not really
true. For one, TikTok’s parent company, ByteDance,
pulled in $80 billion worth of revenue last year,
so the revenue from TikTok US is only about
10%. Still, 10% is not a bad amount right? Well,
that is until you consider that ByteDance
actually lost $7 billion running TikTok. So,
financially speaking, ByteDance will be just fine
without TikTok; in fact, they’ll be better off.
This isn’t to say that ByteDance wants to lose
TikTok but they’re by no means dependent on this
revenue. Do you know who is dependent on TikTok
though? Creators and advertisers who built their
businesses around the platform. So, it’s not
America who’s making TikTok a viable business.
It’s actually ByteDance who’s subsidizing American
creators and advertisers. Think about this.
Every minute, people consume 167 million hours of
TikTok. Assuming that the average TikTok is viewed
for 15 seconds, we’re talking about 668 million
views per minute. According to TikTok themselves,
25% of these views go to American creators which
translates to 167 million views per minute. That’s
the same as 87 trillion views per year. I had to
double check that number like 7 times because it
just seemed so wrong but that’s the number, 87
trillion views. Now, TikTok doesn’t pay very much.
They only pay about 2 to 4 cents per thousand
views. So, that 87 trillion views translates to
just $1.75 billion. But, we all know that the
real money on TikTok isn’t with TikTok ads,
it’s with sponsorships and brand deals. For
creators, TikTok ad revenue is likely at most
5% of their total TikTok revenue meaning that
American creators alone are actually pulling
in closer to $30 to $40 billion through TikTok.
And if companies are paying creators this much,
they’re likely pulling a 3 to 4 times
that themselves. So, we’re talking about a
$100 billion economy here, the vast majority of
which doesn’t even go to TikTok. For perspective,
if TikTok US was a country, it would be rank
63 on the GDP list. And all of this is only
possible because ByteDance is subsidizing
the platform. So, who’s the one who really
needs TikTok to survive. ByteDance or this $100
billion industry? Clearly, it’s the latter, but
TikTok’s influence on the American economy goes
much deeper than just creators and advertisers.
PHASE 2 - WIN INFLUENCE:
TikTok has clearly built a thriving social media
economy in the US but as we previously touched,
this primarily consists of small businesses and
individual creators. The Apples and Coca Colas of
the world don’t really want to get involved.
On one hand, this is a good thing. ByteDance
can argue that a ban on TikTok would simply harm
small business owners like this guy. I mean, do
you really wanna screw up this guy's business? Of
course not. But sympathy only goes so far. If you
really want congress to be on your side, you need
money. Now, the CC I mean ByteDance has plenty of
cash but there’s no chance that they could just
directly lobby Congress. If some congressman
accepts lobbying dollars from ByteDance, they’re
literally advertising that they don’t want to be
reelected so that’s not gonna work. But, what if
you introduced a proxy. A middle man that could
effectively translate cash to political influence.
Hmm, where could you possibly find that?
Oh yeah, the entirety of the big tech industry.
Wasn’t there that one tech company that was
willing to buy TikTok? I think they’re name was
Oracle, why not just partner with them? Oh wait,
that’s exactly what they’re doing. In mid 2022,
TikTok agreed to store all of their US data on
Oracle’s databases and that all traffic
would be routed through Oracle servers.
Don’t mistake this for TikTok actually giving
up control though. They’re going to continue
storing backups themselves because they want to
ensure that they don’t lose access to your data,
I mean, they don’t want you to lose access
to your data. It’s not just Oracle that their
partnering with either. They’ve purchased $800
million worth of cloud services from Google,
they’ve partnered with Microsoft on an AI project,
and they’re integrating Shopify into TikTok. These
partnerships accomplish two goals for TikTok.
For one, these companies can vouch for TikTok
that they are indeed properly storing their
data and not using it for nefarious purposes,
at least not the data that’s stored on Oracle
servers in America. And two, these companies can
work their connections in Congress and persuade
them to go easy on TikTok because well, TikTok is
a big partner/customer for them. This in itself is
a pretty strong case for TikTok but it gets even
better. TikTok can also argue that they’re
supporting big American businesses and even
pushing forward AI development in conjunction with
Microsoft. In reality, all they’re doing is buying
out the support of these big tech companies. But
buying out businesses is just phase 2 of TikTok’s
grand plan. The real power comes from buying out
people which is exactly what they’re doing now.
PHASE 3 - SELL OUTS:
By now, I’m sure you’re
all well aware of the big tech layoffs. Everyone
from Google and Facebook to Microsoft and Amazon
is laying off tens of thousands of people.
This is precisely what ByteDance is doing
as well. They’re also laying off thousands of
people but there’s a caveat. Virtually all of
ByteDance’s layoffs are concentrated in China.
In the meantime, they’re not only maintaining
headcount in America but they’re aggressively
expanding headcount. In fact, they currently
have over 3,400 positions open most of which
are in the US. Now, you might be wondering,
what type of person would take such a big risk and
join such a sketchy company. Well, the answer is
virtually everyone given the right compensation.
And let’s just say, TikTok is hitting compensation
out of the park. Take this data engineer position
for example. There’s nothing especially noteworthy
about this position. It’s not a director position
or a VP position or even a manager position. The
qualifications aren’t that crazy either. They’re
just looking for 1 year of experience in these
basic areas. By all accounts, this is regular
old entry level position. That is until you
look at the compensation. Up to a $250,000 base.
When you throw in stock compensation and bonuses,
you’re easily looking at $300 to $400,000 for an
entry level data engineer position. Let’s take a
look at another one. This one is a Data Scientist
position looking for just 3 years of experience.
For some context, let’s take a look at what
Google pays. For an entry level Data Scientist,
they pay $180,000. That’s already a stellar salary
and one of the best offers you can get. But,
TikTok’s minimum base itself is larger than
Google's total comp. Again, if you throw
in stock and bonus, you’re looking at $300 to
$350 for an entry level position. Hearing that,
I’m sure you’re wondering what TikTok pays for
an actual senior position. Well, here’s a senior
product manager position. TikTok is offering
a base of up to $400,000. For perspective,
even Google’s directors fall $90,000 short of that
base. Also, TikTok isn’t just posting these random
ranges. They’re actually following through with
offers. This guy for example was already making
$345 at Facebook. TikTok, however, came in with
an` offer for $525. Now, if we’re being real,
there’s no way that TikTok actually values
this person’s work contributions at over
half a million per year. They can literally pay
someone in China a tenth of the salary and get
them to work 9 to 9 six days a week. But instead,
TikTok is actively laying people off in China and
replacing them with American counterparts that
are 5 to 10 times as expensive. Why you ask? Well,
it all has to do with optics. That guy isn’t worth
anywhere near half a million per year for TikTok
in terms of work input, but that guy is worth half
a million per year for TikTok in terms of optics.
TikTok already has nearly 7,000 employees
in the US and at the current rate,
this will grow to tens of thousands in no time.
This way, when Congress finally comes around to
taking action on a ban in 6 or 12 months,
TikTok can confidently tell Congress. Yo,
we’re pro American. We’re literally employing
tens of thousands of Americans at salaries that
are 1.5 to 2 times what even Google offers. Do
you really wanna pull the cord this operation?
And that right there is TikTok’s Trump card.
Congress might be able to overlook a bunch of
teens and their little influencer businesses. But,
what they can’t overlook is tens of thousands of
real tech jobs going to Americans. And that
is why TikTok will never be banned. Clearly,
TikTok has played their cards really well
and they aren’t going anywhere anytime soon.
But, the same can’t be said about short form
content. Check out this video to learn more.